hey everyone it's sarah register nurse
rn.com and in this video we're going to
go over
statins and this video is part of an
nclex review series over
pharmacology and as always whenever you
get done watching this youtube video you
can access the free quiz that will test
you on this material
so let's get started suns are used to
lower the cholesterol levels in the body
you may also hear them sometimes
referred to
as hmg coa reductase inhibitors and that
name
is going to make sense and it really
tells us how
these drugs work to lower the
cholesterol levels now
statins are really easy to identify so
when you're going through a patient's
list
all you have to do is look at that
suffix of that medication name the
generic part
and you'll be able to tell if it's a
statin because all these drugs end
in statin so we have like for instance
simvasatin
lovasatin pravasatin etc now what's the
mechanism of action
of statins how do they actually lower
the cholesterol levels in the body
well to help us understand that we have
to talk about the liver
so our liver is an amazing organ and it
does so much for our body
and one of the things it does is it
conducts cholesterol synthesis now
cholesterol synthesis is a very complex
thing that occurs
in the liver and it can't do it
successfully
without the activation of the mevalonate
pathway so the mevalinate pathway is
super complex and from a nursing
standpoint there's just a couple things
that you need to know about it
specifically how statins affect it
so here i have like a very simplified
version of how cholesterol synthesis
happens so
we start here at our starting point and
we have these substances and the main
substance i want you to be familiar with
is hmg coa so in order for
hmg coa to help start this process
it needs to turn into mevalonic
acid and it can't do this unless it has
the help of an
enzyme called hmg coast reductase and
doesn't that look familiar because that
is another name for statins
suns are hmg hmg-coa reductase
inhibitors so this is where statins are
going to work they're going to inhibit
this enzyme from allowing
hmg coa to turn into mevalonic
acid because whenever we get mevolonic
acid on board
that starts the whole mevalinate pathway
and then we get the synthesis of
cholesterol and whenever we inhibit this
what's it going to do it's going to help
lower our cholesterol levels
now why is cholesterol bad why do we
want to lower in the blood
well the thing is we don't want to lower
all types of cholesterol in the blood
some of it's actually very helpful
but what we do want to lower is the ldl
ldl stands for
low density lipoprotein and i want you
to remember the l
that stands for low because it's going
to help you with remembering
what results it should be so this is
really considered the bad cholesterol
because this substance
likes to get in the blood and stick on
our vessel walls and
it can accumulate on those walls and
turn into fatty plaques
and this is termed atherosclerosis and
what happens is as these fatty plaques
grow they can rupture and they can
impede blood flow to whatever structure
they're perfusing so we really don't
want these fatty plaques in our heart
because it can cause a heart attack
because you'll have decreased blood flow
to the heart muscle
and we really don't want them in the
brain because it can decrease blood flow
to the brain and cause a stroke
so generally we want that number less
so low less than 100 milligrams per
deciliter
then on the flip side we have hdl and
this
is known as the good cholesterol and hdl
stands for high density lipoprotein
and we like this number high because the
substance is actually very helpful
in the blood what it does is it will
actually help remove this ldl this bad
cholesterol
so it doesn't have a chance to stick to
those vessel
walls so we like that number generally
greater than 60 milligrams per deciliter
so how statins are really going to work
in a nutshell is that it's going to
hinder this cholesterol synthesis
process
whenever this happens the liver
understands that and it's like oh
okay so what we're going to do is we're
going to increase
the number of ldl receptors and what
that's going to do
is it's going to help further drop that
ldl level
which is good and it actually helps
increase the hdl levels so
the hdl just as i said it's going to
help remove the ldl so we'll help
decrease those levels even more
and we can get a decreased total
cholesterol level
now what conditions are statins used to
treat well we know statins lower the
cholesterol in the blood so they can be
useful in treating patients who have
high cholesterol levels
because it's going to help lower the ldl
increase the hdl
and lower that total cholesterol level
also it can be used
as preventative treatment for patients
who have those certain risk factors
for developing coronary artery disease
related to
atherosclerosis plus it can also be used
in patients who do have
active coronary artery disease to help
stabilize those fatty plaques that are
within their vessels
so they don't rupture and lead to like a
heart attack or stroke
now let's wrap up this review and let's
talk about the nurse's role
for a patient who is taking a statin and
to help us remember that important
information we need to know as nurses
let's remember the word statin so s for
sore
muscles you want to ask your patient are
you having sore muscles or muscle
weakness
now with statins this is a risk that
this can develop and they think that
this is because statins may decrease
the amount of coenzyme q10 in the body
and this enzyme creates muscle cell
energy
so you want to ask your patient about
that and
the physician will probably want to
monitor their creatine kinase level
now why would they want to monitor this
well creatine kinase is a protein
found in skeletal muscle and in the
heart so if we
have high levels of that in the blood
that tells us that our skeletal muscles
are becoming damaged and we'd really
want
to stop this medication if the levels
are getting
higher than 10 times the upper limit
because this could progress to a very
serious condition
known as statin-induced rhabdomyolysis
now what is this well this is a
condition where the skeletal muscles are
becoming very damaged
and what's happening is that myoglobin
is being leaked from those muscles into
the blood
and we know that the kidneys filter our
blood and we don't want myoglobin going
to our kidneys because it can lead to
kidney failure
among other things now there is an
increased
risk of patients developing this
condition if they're taking other drugs
such as
fibrates these are also known as fibric
acid derivatives
and we're talking about drugs like pheno
fibre or gem fibrazil
next is t for toxicity increase with
grapefruit consumption
so you'd want to tell your patient they
want to avoid consuming grapefruit or
grapefruit juice
because this actually increases the
toxicity of statins
then we have a for alt ast
monitored and these are liver enzymes
that we're going to monitor
regularly on a patient who is taking a
statin because liver
failure can occur next t for therapeutic
effects
so as a nurse you want to be familiar
with how statins affect those
cholesterol levels and be able to
educate
your patient on how it affects their ldl
hdl total cholesterol etc so again just
to recap
satin should lower the low density
lipoprotein the ldl that bad cholesterol
and they should increase the hdl
slightly they'll increase it
the high density lipoprotein and it's
going to
lower the total cholesterol along with
helping lower those triglycerides as
well but mainly
it's going to help with that ldl then we
have
eye for increased glucose in patients at
risk for type 2 diabetes
so you want to monitor the blood sugar
teach the patient that as well
teach them of those signs and symptoms
for hyperglycemia
because if they do have those risk
factors for type 2 diabetes it could
increase their glucose level
and then lastly we have n not a cure
statin medications are not a cure
for high cholesterol levels so you want
to tell your patients this
and tell them it's very important they
continue with exercise and a healthy
diet because i have actually had
patients tell me
you know i can eat all the fried food i
want and i really don't have to exercise
because my cholesterol pill will take
care of that
and that's not the case so we really
want to educate patients and inform them
that this medication is not a cure
okay so that wraps up this review over
statins and don't forget to check out
the other videos in this pharmacology
series and to access the free quiz that
will test you
on this content